I was eight years old my mother died she  loved traveling the world and digging up  the past he used to visit all the time  no one day everything changed she had  found something something he wanted he  would have killed me too I got away  [Applause]  has changed  [Music]  nothing could stand in the face of this  we are London  before she died  your mother told me she was afraid of  Valentine and that if anything should  happen to her I was to find you that you  can stop him  she could be a problem if she's anything  like a mother people what happens when  you find a stash or  [Music]  he's here  game of survival this is checkmate  honey you wouldn't leave me shut up and  run you sure you want to do this I have  to my mother  get her and all you see by the jagged  edges but she is something quite  different she is beautiful and strange  and very very rare  you  [Music]  you